everybody it's Charlie we got new flash
to break down let's do it
flash family is back probably one of the
best episodes of the season next to
therefore I am that thinker origin story
so there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a flash
related comment on the video and
obviously careful for spoilers from the
episode but number 10 the entire episode
takes place over the course of a couple
minutes so I love the way that they
played with that clock at the beginning
of the episode and they're really
careful to tease concepts I felt like
they did a good job
leaving the logic and covering all their
bases like how come they couldn't do X Y
or Z thing with the bomb they had all
those different explainers for why that
wasn't possible and it was mostly
because running it out of town would
speed up the reaction and also the bomb
had already gone off when she alerted
Baird to the fact that she had the
trigger but they also liked having the
speed equation up on the board at the
beginning they're in the speed lab it
was a very speedster heavy episode so I
felt like that's also one of the reasons
why it was one of the best of the season
they're always a lot of fun even if you
don't open portals to the Speed Force or
cause giant showers of Speed Force
Lightning but the other thing they did
in this episode was sort of remind you
of a couple of the big core concepts in
the big twist of the season like Barry
and iris are married they're husband and
wife they haven't spent a whole lot of
time addressing that or them just doing
regular people's stuff like most of the
season has been about their fight
against the thinker but there's a lot of
other family stuff going on like this is
a flash family episode there's also the
literal family that they will eventually
have because at some point in the future
presumably they'll have the twins then
they'll be what you would think of when
you think of a traditional family but
the thing that iris says that they sort
of bring back around to the solution of
the episode is let the answer come to
you so he was literally using that
device at the end of the episode to let
the lightning come to him so I was like
when they turn those metaphors
especially if they seem like offhanded
thinks into literal solutions to the
episode by the very end stray
observations - went futon wrap Dib knee
is moving into STAR Labs
even though he wasn't in this episode
but they just want to let you know that
he's going to be living at STAR Labs
eventually number 9 Jesse quick comes
back they have
those funny moments and her arc is all
about the death of her mother Harrison
wells you learned a little bit about the
backstory and why it was she kicked him
off the team and they resolved it in a
really beautiful way so number eight was
actually their ending of the story where
he uses the neural inhibitor to
literally allow her into his minds so
that she can hear his thoughts about her
mother and sort of experience it with
him so they're on the same page now but
I'm also curious to see if they use that
twist for something else later this
season like allow someone to listen to
the thoughts of another person that
could be used in the fight against a
vote but it could also be used for more
fun things on team flash remember what
sabotage said using the neural inhibitor
against DeVoe they might just use it in
a way that you didn't think that they
were going to use it I like that they
also reference wall-e while he's not
here as if she came to talk to Wally
like no just here for dad's stuff she's
gonna be on legends of tomorrow in their
next episode that visit might have been
inspired by the moment she shared with
her father like you know telling the
people that you care about how you feel
and communicating with them in a more
meaningful way
but number seven the bomb goes off and
you get that early montage of them
trying a bunch of different things like
they try killer frost they try Cisco's
vibing none of it's gonna work you
notice that everybody who's not a
speedster gets tired really fast and
breaks into a flop sweat almost
immediately just because their bodies
can't handle flash time number six the
flash time explainer so you get a much
better picture of how things work if you
thought it was weird the way they filmed
things because like sometimes they'd be
in flash time running at SuperSpeed I
think what they were doing there which
is forcing perspective because like the
best way to visualize it is when Barry
is running very slowly across the city
like that kind of gives you an idea that
he's running at SuperSpeed
but we're seeing it more in his time so
it's almost like he's just jogging but
technically inside flash time if you saw
another speedster running he would just
look like they were jogging like a
normal person but stray observation iris
did not sweat nor did she get tired
while they were in flash time and she
was in there for about the same amount
of time as Cisco and killer frost so it
doesn't necessarily mean anything but
just keep that in the back of your mind
as we learn more about iris through the
rest of the episodes number five Jay
Garrick was off
john wesley shipp is always great ways
on the show but I love the idea that he
is just like all hell no when Barry says
that they blow up the Speed Force with
the bomb you have no idea what's gonna
happen and he does actually explain it
in a really good way
it's pan-dimensional so you blow up the
Speed Force it blows up everywhere in
the multiverse in all the speedsters
both good and bad lose their connection
to it so even though some good would
come of it you'd save the city from
being destroyed by the bomb and you'd
also get rid of eobard thawne's speed
the potential cost completely outweigh
that because you have to keep in mind
this is the entire multiverse we're
talking about and we have one city of a
couple hundred thousand people so what
are the lives of a couple hundred
thousand people against the lives of all
the people in the multiverse that
Flash's potentially save over their
lifetimes so you can argue about that in
the comments right or wrong whatever you
think the decision was but I think we
can all say that we don't want them to
blow up the Speed Force anytime soon
Barry had that same oh hell no when
Jesse quit was like why don't we just
travel back in time and fix this he has
to give her that flash point explain her
like just trust me bad things happen to
the people you love when you mess with
the timeline so what should we call this
brave new world that you've whipped up
for us I was thinking number three the
actual solution is something that
predates Barry coming back on the show
that's why iris had to remind him and
why Barry didn't know about it because
after they brought him out of the Speed
Force
nobody really sat him down to explain
the mechanics of how they brought him
out they didn't tell him about that
device so iris is like when we brought
you out Cisco created this device for
calling out the Speed Force so use this
as the lightning rod to literally draw
the lightning out so I always like it
when they reference comic book stuff
like that too because I think the show
has addressed the idea of Iris being
Barry's lightning rod but not very
frequently usually it's when Barry's
been stuck in the Speed Force and
they've used iris to help draw him out I
think it was back during season two and
they kind of stepped around it during
season three when he came out of the
Speed Force
[Music]
but number two of course the idea is
what are the consequences of this
because remember what happened when he
came out of the speedforce at the
beginning of the season he doused all
the bus metas in dark matter energy and
we found out that somebody else tipped
the terrorists off to where this bomb
was so it sounds like DeVoe wanted Barry
to open a portal to the Speed Force
again so that he could get access to
that dark matter for what purpose we
don't know yet because you can do just
about anything with it they haven't
explained the Speed Force well enough to
narrow that down
they're very ambiguous about what it's
capable of and that's just so they can
have fun with it later on if they want
to come up with some crazy story like ah
we have the Speed Force creating some
more metas but you can post all your
theories in the comments below like
it'll take a couple more episodes before
we'll learn what that is but remember
this is really like the back half of the
season so it's not like they're gonna
drag this out that much but number two
was Jay Garrick effectively retiring or
saying that he was getting ready to
retire I think you know by the end of
the show's run the ideas that he becomes
retired and Jesse quick takes his place
as the speedster of Earth three I'm
thinking about trying my hand at
something new like what for starters
training someone to take over there's
another flash on yours it will be as
soon as I'm done training her
when do you think we're good with the
speedforce
is not we'll find out soon enough so if
there was any confusion about when he
said that a her would be training to
replace him he was probably talking
about Jessie quick not some unknown
female speedster that we haven't met yet
because I think the idea is is that
Harrison wells will eventually go back
to earth-2 so they won't have as much of
a need for a speedster but you never
know like the show is just building room
for more speedsters to appear the actors
the plays Jesse quick was actually just
cast on another TV show so I think that
she's not gonna be quite as available
next season so I think it is totally
possible they use wall-e more or they
bring more speedsters on the TV show in
the future they just have more room for
them in the narrative but let it be
known the Jay Garrick Jessie quick will
always come back to the show I do that
whole big explainer about Mark Hamill
coming back as the trickster waiting til
John Wesley Shipp was available at the
same time so when they come back they
might come back together in an episode
but number one of course was coffee shop
girl coming back in a really weird twist
- so she was meeting Caitlyn in Harrison
wells like she said she was meeting
someone for the first time she was
wearing Caitlin's metahuman dampener
choker from the first episode again
Caitlin didn't notice it or say anything
about it I'm really very very sorry
don't worry about it good luck because
thanks
[Music]
it did but I think part of the idea this
too part of her mission whatever mission
she's on is meeting all the different
members of team flash and these were
just the next two on her list so this
kind of explains why she's using jitters
because all of the team flash members
come to jitters every once in a while so
there's still a couple people that she
hasn't met most notably iris in Cecile
Cecile's pregnant I know there's like
fifty percent of people that want coffee
shop girl to be Cecile's baby the other
fifty percent want her to be irises baby
and be one of the tornado twins I will
go on record as saying I'll be super
super disappointed if it turns out that
it's Cecile's baby I'm hoping that we
find out that iris is pregnant in the
final episode but that's still several
weeks away so just look for more clues
as we go along we'll see more of coffee
shop girls so we'll get some more
evidence about what it is that she's
actually up to besides just trying to
meet all the different members of team
flash and scribbling the same symbols
that Barry was writing when he came out
of the Speed Force well let me know in
the comments after this episode what is
your favorite episode of season four so
far I'll do a trailer video for run iris
run tomorrow we already know a little
bit about how she gets her powers and
the mechanics of everything in the
timeline so that should be up pretty
early in the morning I've also got some
new witcher because speak of mark hamill
the witcher TV series might be casting
him is one of the bigger characters so
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Milan Abraham please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for my infinity war
Black Order preview and click here for
that legends of tomorrow wally west
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight